welcome to academy dialogues it starts
with us
my name is sean finney we are continuing
our ongoing series of conversations
about race ethnicity
history opportunity and the art of
filmmaking
today's discussion group will explore
the invisibility of latinos in hollywood
the complexity of latin identity
legacies of colonialism and solutions to
advance representation
moderating today's conversation is
lorenzo munoz evp
member relations and awards at the
academy of motion pictures arts and
sciences
victoria alonzo evp production marvel
studios
casting director producer carmen guba
director nadia halgren actress producer
director and businesswoman eva
longoria and marketing strategist yvette
rodriguez
we look forward to your conversation
today hello everybody
welcome mujeres it's so wonderful to
have you all here
it's it's such a dream for me
to be able to host this conversation
that
is absolutely necessary and i think
we're all gonna
really enjoy and commune over so
uh without much further ado let's let's
get started
uh so tell us what brought you to
hollywood
what was your story and what have you
faced along the way
let's start with eva of course you start
with me as my son
is marching through the room mama loves
you
um so yeah you know my gosh my journey's
been a long one i
uh i never wanted to be an actor i
didn't even know about the industry i
grew up in corpus jersey texas
uh and we had a tv we didn't even go to
the movies because
it was just too expensive we would go to
the dollar cinemas
which were the movies that were out
already for a very long time
um so that was as close as i got to
experience in hollywood but
i don't know what happened i went to
college and one day i said
i'm gonna be an actor and i told my mom
i said i think i'm gonna i'm gonna
become an actor and move to la
with 200 in my bank account and went and
got a job and just figured it out
i figured it out i think um
my journey to today which is more
directing and producing
uh people always think i'm an actor
turned director producer but i always
tell people i was always
a director producer who happened to fall
into acting as a means to the end of
becoming a director
uh but uh for me it's just been it's
been a fun journey because i remember
arriving in hollywood and not being
latina enough because i didn't speak
spanish and i didn't have an accent
and every audition i went on they were
like uh you know
uh you know could you do it more like
rosie perez
and i was like well i um i
don't i'm not from new york i'm not
puerto rican
like that's a specific dialect and then
uh
and i didn't speak spanish so i couldn't
go out in spanish language things either
so i wasn't latin enough and then i
wasn't white enough and uh
and so i got italian roles
i was like great i'll take it i will do
that role
for a long time and and what it made me
realize in the industry was
obviously stereotypes and what people
think a latina should sound like or look
like
but also uh that hollywood thought we
were monolithic
that there's not afro latinas that we're
all
of one um sexuality that we are all
supposed to be
gorgeous and and sexy and uh
feisty i remember i kept getting a note
when i was on younger story could you do
it more
latina and i'm like i am latina like
i can't do it anymore latina because
i am ladina and so um there was a big
learning curve for our industry and i
think that today people always go how
are we doing today and i said you know
we're facing the right direction now i
don't know we've taken enough steps in
the right direction but there's at least
we're
facing the right direction and we're
having these conversations which is
really important
that's wonderful yeah and as you can see
from our beautiful panel how different
we all
are and we are all latinas it's
wonderful our diversity
gosh i don't know i was never supposed
to be in hollywood i
you know i grew up in argentina born and
raised
i'm a teenager of the military
dictatorship
where um i always say that the theater
saved my life
so because instead of being in marches i
was at the theater
uh playing rehearsing and
i was very involved in the marches so um
i i
often have told the story of i i used to
hold the banners
uh in the front row i know that's a
surprise uh
and because the banners were so heavy we
ended up
i ended up like staying back two three
rows and
but when they shot they shot at the
first row in the second row and
by the time that the third row was about
to be hit we we had a chance to run
so all that to say that um
when i when i wanted to study something
i studied theater and psychology
because that's what my father was and
that was a chance for me to get close to
him and he died at the age of 40. so he
died very young and i was very little
um when i came to the states i had never
thought that i would be in production
and i had in la i had three jobs
and i worked at alaska airlines at five
in the morning five to twelve
for a long time um and then i will go to
permanent pictures to be a page
and i did all the live shows and then
i'll during the weekends i would have a
black angus waitress job this is with i
had a full
college education already finished but i
was trying to figure out what i was
doing
and i tell you the last caroline's uh
story because i think it's important a
friend of mine on the last card line
said
hey i think you'd be great in production
i'm like what is production because i
was doing uh
i was helping produce a show called
frida kahlo at the bilingual foundation
of the arts
and she said i have a friend that works
in production you should meet with her
so i got to meet with carla and she
gives me my first pa job
um that to say from there on that was
almost 30 years ago but
when we did captain marvel i worked at
alaska airlines and i didn't i didn't
want to ask my mother for money
um so i had the three jobs and i had
jobs that gave me food alaska airlines
gave me
the leftover uh food from first class
because i threw it away i ate it
daily and i took it home um
then i would go to the shows the live
shows are paramount they fed all of us
that was beautiful i ate that night and
on the weekends i'm argentinian no
denying there
i ate steak at blackhands for a reduced
price
um when we did captain marvel alaska
redlines
had um a couple of planes with captain
marvel on it and i remember being in a
marketing
meeting and i saw it and i
just that i said nothing i was just
my tears were coming down what full
circle
to those days look i'm talking about a
plane
and here's the santa monica airport
gives us the playing q sound i love it
this is a great time
i remember thinking if you would have
written it
there's they would have said no that's a
little too much you know that you go
from
that you go from eating the food and
working
uh at the last current lens to having
their plane having our film that was one
of the pinnacles
alongside with black panther i always
say this
pinnacles of my career so
from production from pa to now
alongside with lou and kevin heading the
studio i'm on my 30th marvel film and
my eighth is an eighth streaming show
and second animation show so we
anyway long story to tell you all that
amazing trajectory and game changing
what you've done
um nadia hallgren tell us about your
journey
wow so my journey i still don't feel
hollywood um i feel like documentary
i never imagined uh being a documentary
documentary filmmaker would
land me somehow anywhere near hollywood
i'm born and raised in south bronx
and i started being interested in
documentary through
a community photography program that my
mom encouraged me to go to
at the international center photography
and
it just really kind of stirred up this
interest and storytelling
and gave me an opportunity to try and
make sense of the world that i lived in
um and then you know i started making
short films and through
you know the biggest stroke of luck in
my life
i met um one of michael moore's
producers
at a community uh film festival in the
bronx
and she gave me her name's tia lesson
she gave me my very first job as a pa
as well which is i always think those
are great stories working on fahrenheit
911
and um at that point i
decided that i wanted to be a
cinematographer i felt like
being a dp gave me an opportunity to not
have to speak
i could show up on set i could be quiet
and not have to sort of expose
my what i thought was like my lack of
education or that
i kind of came you know from the hood um
before i worked in film i was a
nightclub bouncer
um and uh i
worked you know worked my way up
started working as a dp and then
ultimately started
directing um documentaries and that's
how i'm here
awesome i love that you were a bouncer
that's so cool you know me so you can
probably now imagine that
i'm sure there's a thousand stories that
we can hear from yes
we could just do the whole thing on that
oh my god
listen that's a good documentary too
nadia it is
i love it um carmen cuba
tell us your story um
yeah well like most of us so far this
was not my plan
um my father is peruvian
and was a political economist for the
the un
growing up and my mom is american of
dutch and italian descent and was a
spanish teacher who started
her sort of connection to latin america
at 15 when she was an exchange student
she was a she had skipped various grades
and she was an exchange student in
college in columbia
so my two parents met both being fluent
speaker
well my father was not a fluent american
english speaker but my mother spoke
spanish fluently and they met in college
and um had me and i lived between peru
and bolivia
very very immersed peru bolivia and
um eventually new mexico but i was very
immersed
in a world w that was surrounded by
people from all over the world from
birth um
[Music]
many of my parents colleagues were
you know from all over the world i went
to an international school in
bolivia so my first friends were
african and anyway that's just to say
that
this sort the stage was set for me to
explore and be very interested in humans
um from all different backgrounds from
myself and have you know i come from
a great respect for that that idea of
authentic
diversity and the lives that we actually
live
and um when i moved to the states i
moved to
in when i was around 11 i moved to new
mexico which is
another very complicated ethnic
sort of mix and there my mom got me
involved
in um like nadia your mom my mom got me
involved in a
in a bilingual theater group and it was
one of only three
in the country at the time and it was
run by
an openly gay puerto rican
hiv-positive man and so that was sort of
my and he was in new mexico
trying to tell these stories with
non-professional actors
he was trying to start a real community
theater company a lot of it focusing on
who who are new mexicans and who are we
so in that i ran lights i did sound i
you know was on stage i i was one of
only two kids because it was all it was
really adults
so i came up through that all the while
thinking i needed to have you know a
real job
when i grew up so i went into journalism
and i studied journalism
and then from there i was a
news reporter on univision back when
there were only three channels in new
mexico and only one of them was
spanish-speaking so i did that and then
i came to
to but actually when i was doing that i
realized that
i love people and i love stories and
doing news you only got
you know sort of this accident happened
here's the person
who what where when why and i always
wanted to follow those people home and
a month later and be like so how did it
affect you
um and so i i really
always have really connected to these
human stories so i came to
la because a boyfriend
that i had in college lived here and um
and i pursued document i thought i
was going to pursue documentary film and
one thing led someone like victoria it's
like someone suggested i meet someone
and suddenly i was
in post-production on the second season
of the real world
which was shooting in los angeles which
at the time was
a it was a true documentary it wasn't
reality tv it was really about the
people
and anyway so then i sort of worked my
way through that and they
suggested i try casting since i was a
journalist and
they didn't no one knew what casting was
back then of that so
i did that for a while and loved it and
i
you know even back then i had a they did
a spin-off show called road rules and
it was about this group of kids
traveling across america and to me
because at that
i also lived on a navajo reservation um
for one of the years that i was after i
moved to new mexico
and uh so i put the first native
american person
on mtv in the 90s and to me that was
just made total sense because it was
you know the first show of kids
traveling across
america um so anyway
it's always been part of my my life and
from there
when things became reality tv somebody
suggested that i
try narrative and i said yes and
that's how i am here today
wonderful wow that's amazing i was an
exchange student too
oh wow in san diego and
you know i showed up and all you know i
come from the the dictatorship right
uniforms you can do all these things
here all these girls and boys and their
swimming suits and flip flops and they
didn't have a lot of clothes
in school and i i was appalled i was
like they're going to come and get them
this is not going to go well and it took
me like three months to get it that they
were not in trouble
um anyway we digress
it's it's funny how all of our cultural
you know stuff that comes with us right
like i'm from mexico
and when i came here in the summer when
i was
six years old and in mexico a lot of
people go
oh yeah right and
and the the camp counselor looked at me
and she was like
in america we don't do that i'm not a
doctor
so that was my first foray into oh okay
this is what i do now
in mexico for yes yeah so if
you're if somebody says something you go
and so i do this in meetings now and
people go
do you have a question
[Laughter]
no no i'm agreeing with
oh you oh
and yvette yvette rodriguez tell us your
story
my story hi um well i was born in puerto
rico
and i moved to new jersey to a small
town in new jersey 45 minutes from the
city with my parents
actually on american airlines with all
the rodriguez's we all moved to this
little small town
and um and and i was raised it was very
much a working-class town and i was i
grew up with polish people and i
italian african-american like everybody
worked for johnson and johnson or ford
so
we all owned homes and the american
dream right that's what i
grew up in and then cut to but you know
definitely no understanding that there
was an industry like i didn't understand
there was a film industry
or a record industry you like the best
thing you can think of is you know
you're going to become a doctor or a
lawyer
this was you know what you aspired to do
and i was in new york city going to
school
and working as a paralegal at a law firm
when my nate when my roommate came home
and told me that she had just gone for a
job interview at arista records and
she was appalled because they weren't
pay their i don't even remember what the
amount was but it was not a high-paying
job and she had already graduated
college
so then i decided that i would go that i
would like the opportunity to experience
a job interview
and i went for a job interview at 6 west
57th street and when i got off on the
7th floor
i saw all these gold and platinum
records on the wall
and i was like oh my god where am i
i had no idea growing up loving film
loving music but not
not being sophisticated enough to know
that there was an industry
so at that point i met with my who
became my mentor i
interviewed with her and at the end of
the interview i extended my hand to her
and i said thank you for your time
i can start monday and she said okay
we'll see you then
and that was the beginning of my career
at aristotle records clive davis
you know first artist was whitney
houston um
but you know immediately i noticed that
i was i didn't know i was different
actually until i started working
and because people wanted my opinion
about things that i didn't understand
why because i was a jersey girl rock and
roll girl like
why and it was because of the color of
my skin i quickly understood
and so cut two orion pictures which is
why this is really
full circle they just announced what
they announced but orion pictures was
nearby and i could see
the posters on the wall when you walk i
would walk for lunch and i would look up
and those were movie posters i was like
oh my god what is this
and then we worked on the soundtrack for
dying young julia roberts i was like a
big fan of julia roberts and we get to
work on the soundtrack
because kenny g um did the main theme
song
and i went to my first screening right
to meet with the publicity department
from the studio
and i was like oh my god what is this
right
and so i moved west i moved west to get
into the film industry
and um i started and i was in the
in the records in the studio and uh
quickly understood that i was different
um
just being in meetings really being the
only brown person i'm aging myself but
this is a really long time ago we've
come a long way but nowhere near where
we need to
be but i remember
like a feeling when the studio executive
the head of a studio
came to me to excited to let me know
that he now understood my culture
because he just got done seeing a film
about a puerto rican in the south bend
like a poverty stricken puerto rican in
the south bronx
and i was and he says i really
understand your culture now this is a
true story i was like
oh okay i mean it was just like
i didn't even say anything and people
that know me will say i don't believe
you didn't say anything i didn't say
anything
i found my voice later in life i was
just shocked but that's happened a lot
to me
and so i think i i was always a little
activist at heart
and um actually my experience
both of these experiences in records and
in film actually propelled my career so
i started my own company in 1997
specifically called it american
entertainment market because i was like
hello we are american
and um and so it was just to like
authentically
con you know connect with the latino
consumer
and um so it's interesting that
hollywood has pushed for this
industry has pushed me um to start my
own company and now pushed me
to want to produce my own films so you
know this is a
that's my story i hope it's my full
story
so what movie did you see that dude oh
you're gonna ask me that
now we're gonna know who it is
i bet we can guess if she tells us the
year because there was one movie every
five years man it was a puerto rican
movie
was it west side story no
was it i like it like that molina was
mexican-american
sorry charades
well that leads us to the next question
which is about stereotypes right and how
i think eva also touched on this as well
is this
just this general perception of us
that's either
you're feisty you're angry you're fiery
what a temper you're
so sexy you're so hot you're so you're
the maid
you're the chola you're the like there
are
all of these stereotypes that we all
have all had to deal with
um tell us some of your stories and we
we can start with
nadia wow um
i think for me
especially you know i i came up and i
still am just behind the camera
you know as a cinematographer and
someone on like the technical side
i i think the main experience that i had
that was always a little bit crushing
was you know the minute i walked in the
room people had no idea what i was doing
there
you know it would be typically uh a crew
looked like a room full of white men um
and when i walked in you know it was
like what
what are you doing here and it was this
like up and down look a lot at my hair
you know i would try to even consider if
that day i was going to work if it was
very humid out you know how i can like
not bring so much attention to myself
but
you know that was something very uh
common that happened and even though
it's a look it's just this feeling that
then sits with you an entire day of work
um and i think you know
something that surpri i guess surprised
me and it shouldn't have was
i thought as i moved up in you know
experience and credits that um
i would get treated differently but the
um the amount
of times that i'm just completely
underestimated
in my job and my ability at times
is um yeah i think
it just speaks to systemically this
stereotype that is you know rampant in
all industries but just
you know about where we come from our
in intellect you know our abilities and
i think that that's just that's
definitely
um probably one of them the things that
have
i've had to work within myself and
within the people that i collaborate
with the most to
try and create an environment that you
know makes it possible to show up to
work every day and
and and be happy and satisfied with
with the process you know yes it's so
funny because i think that is something
uh we have the double whammy because
we're women and we're people of color
and dimming our light when we go on a
set especially as a director
i remember i had a guy tell me after i
we finished directing
an episode of something he goes you know
you're you're good
and i was like what a jerk thank you
as if he expected you weren't yeah he
expected me not to be good
um and so that that dimming your light
and and like i just don't i want to be
small
and not not have anybody notice me
and i was directing while breastfeeding
i had just had my baby
and i said oh my god i don't want the
guys the 90 of the crew
to feel i didn't want them to feel
uncomfortable that's i was worried about
them feeling as i was like i'm going to
take breaks to breath to pump and then
to breastfeed
and it's like dimming our light for that
for who why
like be good be be your best and let
everybody deal with it but i've oh yeah
i felt that way too nadia you know
you're like oh should i wear my hair
different
i'm always thinking about what to wear
to set because i want to be comfortable
but i don't want to look like a slob and
then i'm a girl but i don't want to be
girly and it's like it's so much you
have to navigate
because you want to be seen as a boss
you know and it's too much to think
about before you're even like doing the
work right
like that's not hard enough it's like we
don't even know what they feel
because they've never had to have that
little chapter of the book
um which we do i i often i i
to i don't know that i've been
discriminated i am pretty loud and
feisty and i i
tend to advocate to the to the good
stereotypes of who we are as passionate
women but
i um i tell the story like i would say
halfway into our successful career
marvel came this man that came to
pitch as a director i've told the story
before is the story of the coffee
and when you're about to be
interviewed at marvel if you're one of
the two
people that were trying to decide who is
who
that you get to meet luke kevin and
myself and
usually there's they created the other
creative producer there's four of us
that will walk it through
and you've met with the other person but
you haven't met the three of us we were
running
so late for this meeting and and they
could the other the fourth producer had
gone already to say
i'm sorry they're running late i'm sorry
the guys
because we're always the guys and i'm
i'm a part of that and i'm okay with it
the guys are running behind the right so
finally i leave the meeting that i'm
with kevin and lou and i said you know
what
one of us needs to show the face we're
like way behind now
i go i'll go and i'll tell when i get
there
and uh and i said gosh i am so sorry
running really behind ca have they even
asked you do you
want anything can i get you anything to
drink or i want coffee
i want coffee with milk and i want it
now
i said oh and i thought wow
you are nervous and i'm thinking okay
well let's
walk over uh over here the conference
room was here
and there was a little coffee area there
and uh but a true true jerk
and so i'm making the coffee and i'm
thinking because you know i'm
argentinian so i battle
my eagle all day making the coffee
you're making the coffee
wait i'm not done longoria
so i go in i make the coffee and i put
an equal and i don't put milk
he wanted sugar and milk and he goes god
damn it i told you i did not want and i
said
no no no i i heard what you wanted this
is my coffee
now i walk you through how the coffee
machine works
you saw me do it i'm sure you were quick
to learn
i will be right back with the guys so
enjoy your coffee
and i walked out and that was that
moment where
you can let the ego be alive and well i
could have said all kinds of things
i could have said all kinds of things
because to be honest with you they were
in my head they were like
and i was like
and i thought you know what i won't
forget this moment
i'm sure he won't forget this moment and
so
i walked away three of us came in and he
was
purple purple when i walked in he was
like
oh my god now needless to say he pitched
it wasn't a good pitch and he didn't get
the job which is always what they asked
me did he get the job
but it had nothing to do with the fact
that he was a jerk the pitch was not a
good pitch
uh but even at that moment in time where
we had made 10 billion dollars worth of
successful films
we had had the first avenger movies out
we've had many movies i mean like i
don't know i think we were a
movie number or will be 30 now which is
a different kind of success but
at that moment in time in a movie
whatever 10 that we were or 8
we had the the kind of success that
people talk about right because if you
have one movie that makes a lot of money
people talk about it
uh but even at that moment in time the
assumption was that i was
the girl that i would have taken notes
or i would have made him coffee
armin tell us your stories well it's
interesting listening to that pic
all of that because i think because i
have peruvian and american
in my you know family and my
in my experience i sort of grew up
uh you know my my mother's family is
from
queens um and my
grandfather who i was very close to is a
nypd
lieutenant and i'm sure
you know the story is i was his favorite
and yet
when he was introducing me to people he
would say this is my puerto rican
granddaughter and but he didn't know the
difference between puerto rico and peru
at you know it's like in the 70s early
70s and
my mom his daughter was so mortified and
mad
all the time and i was like it doesn't
matter to me
like i love him he loves me it's
fine so i think growing up feeling like
oh
people just don't know um
sort of set the stage for me because i
don't i don't
really notice it in a way because i've
been able to be successful
despite whatever has maybe been whatever
bias has come my way and also i have the
lorenzo we talked about this a little i
have the the
privilege of sort of ethnic ambiguity
which is a thing too you know it's like
people
they mostly think i'm asian so
that experience is i don't know what
people think but i know
that they don't know what i actually am
most of the time until they ask
and so i do think i've had privilege in
that
that way and i think like all of us we
have these different privileges as well
as these
biases against us or if you're tall if
you're
look a certain way if you you know so
um i would say that my ethnic ambiguity
has actually given me a lot of
permission to
do make a lot of moves in inside the
dominant culture of hollywood and
inside the mainstream movies that i've
worked on because i can
sort of suggest something that someone
else would not have suggested and i pre
i have
actually gotten mostly very positive
response like when i say oh that
you know in bowfinger shouldn't that
shopkeeper couldn't that shopkeep
keeper be asian and and and then i
present them john cho and they go oh
yeah
but if i wasn't there and i hadn't
presented that
it would have been white because that's
just the default and certainly back then
it's much better now
but um anyway i don't know if that
answers the question
no it's so funny because i had that
privilege too because i didn't have an
accent
people assumed i actually many times
that i was white
and so they would be like latino that
latino and i'm like well i'm
i'm one of them like don't forget they
would forget
uh you know it's for me i have
to talk about stereotypes specifically
because i i'm listening i feel like we
all have the same experience i'm like
have i been discriminated against
because of my ethnicity i think we've
all experienced a lot of sexism
um and i've spoken to a lot of women
of color and they always go what's
what's the cross you bear and they would
say oh
definitely because i'm a woman not so
much because i'm a latina woman but a
woman
um but stereotypes in the media so like
if you're talking about
storytelling the danger
there's two sides of the coin and i have
two opinions about it because i produced
a um
i produced a show called devious maids i
produced and directed it
and the the backlash because i was
latina
doing a a show about maids um
you know i was like wow why are you
stereotyping us again or whatever
and then if you saw the show the maids
were the moral compass
of the story and the employers were the
[ __ ] and the idiots we were making a
point about how you treat
domestic workers and
and i also took offense that you think
those people don't have stories to tell
gardeners domestic workers nannies maids
you're saying their lives don't matter
so
when you think about gangbangers or
things in movies
we have to be careful how we tell the
story but if you give them life
and reason and make them the the point
of view in which we are
telling the story then that's a
different thing if you're using them
frivolously in a movie as a caricature
of what people think they should be
then that's offensive but but in
storytelling i think it's important to
make sure that we do tell those stories
you know if you saw damian bishid in
um a better life your heart
rips out of your body because
he was a a father trying to protect his
son
and if we humanize this the
the people of our community and we give
them stories and lives
that are worth telling then people will
maybe see
them as human instead of
other and instead of from there and
instead of go back to where you came
from
um i thought you know once this children
in cages on the border happen
i thought oh mom's everywhere we're
gonna get so much support because
any mother knows how that feels and we
didn't
and you know why because we haven't
shown that these people at the border
crossing with their children
are moms we have to humanize these
people and so
sometimes when you talk about
stereotypes when i think about it in the
narrative storytelling
way we have i think we have to tell
those stories we can't
shy away and not tell them that's such a
great point eva and
and i think it leads us into the next
next question about our invisibility too
as a community and the data that has
been
compiled particularly by stacy smith at
usc
that in front of the camera behind the
camera we're just
missing we're 18 of the population in
this country and yet
we are in the low four percent
three percent uh in terms of it just in
front of the camera so
uh everybody jump in please eva i'm sure
you have a perspective on this as well
i have a very strong perspective on this
because i think uh
and i'll be quick but um no matter what
part of the
film ecosystem we're talking about uh
latinos are vastly underrepresented
writer director producer actor
casting director stunt coordinator crew
members
first acs camera operator every part of
the pipeline
you do not see uh latinos and and this
is at a time where latinos in our
country are facing intense
concern about our safety you know that
we we are being attacked
daily uh in our communities and so to
have authentic
and accurate representation throughout
entertainment is important
and and the interesting thing about
stacy smith's study is she didn't call
it underrepresentation of latinos in
hollywood she called it the erasure of
latino community
the erasure because what happens is
that void that
is happening in the entertainment
industry is being
filled by hateful violent rhetoric
through news and so uh it's imperative
that you know talented storytellers from
our community are given opportunities to
tell diverse and vibrant
narratives because um it actually boils
down to the safety
uh our safety in this country i'd also
like to make a point here um as it
relates to invisibility because really
um where it all begins is that we are
absent from our history books so k
through 12
there is absolutely um we're not
educating our own children
nor are we educating other children
about our contribution then you go into
higher learning
same thing so we are we are completely
erased and so
hollywood that has such an incredible
opportunity to it
actually shapes perception right they're
erasing us completely
so therefore that's why you can you know
people to eva's point
like there are babies brown babies in
cages and people can walk
with and just sleep at night with no
problem so the problem
is is it's a really large problem
especially when you look at
not only 18 of the population our
purchasing power the fact that this
economy does not work without amer
without american latinos it just doesn't
so like if you and also if you look at
our population first of all globe
population right let's look at the
numbers
like what percentage of people in the
world are white versus
the rest of us like it's just common
sense numbers it's business it's
catching up with hollywood so at this
point it's like
you got to start from the very top like
the board of directors the ceos
because it's all about money right it's
obviously also about
about healing right like to be able to
see us as human there are 60 million
plus stories in this country alone that
you're missing out
on and they're you just keep
perpetuating the same story over and
over again
and so um and i think that growing up in
this environment
you know i learned to code switch in a
very early age and i didn't even truly
understand it until like the last decade
like really understand that i sort of
was proud that i could sit in a room
with a bunch of white people and fit in
because i spoke english in a certain way
and it wasn't until i realized like how
much that really has affected me
i am puerto rican in my blood
is african ancestry it is
you know european ancestry and
indigenous
and i am the colonized and the colonizer
and um and so i think that we're now
sort of like coming together as latinos
from all walks of life whether you're
mexican
wherever it is and i feel like we're
we're coming together more now and we're
really truly not going to ask for
permission anymore and we're working
together i'm seeing that
like i'm seeing a movement in that way
it's also that people always think that
latinos are the dark skinned people
i am as latinas they come but i never
get involved
i never get included well you're white
aren't you
no i'm not i'm not well argentinians are
kind of white i'm like
i mean that's the other side of the
court yeah we can well as you can see i
mean with i've been out of my yard for a
long time now it's 187 days but
hey it was counting um but
we are you know i'm sure carmen you
probably suffer
some of that although you you do have
american
uh heritage but mine is italian spaniard
and where do we fit in is it
i mean if i don't say my last name
people think i'm from holland
don't ask me why but i've been i've been
i've been asked if i'm dutch
more times than greek
or italian or spam i mean like i don't
know
so it's within even within our community
i'm not just saying white america i'm
telling you
latinos in america we don't even know
how
vast our palette of shades and colors we
are
and we tend to sort of exclude one
another
by doing that unless somebody sees your
last name or
hears an accent i mean i take every box
right i was
came here very young as an exchange
student i was 15 and then
at 19 i moved i didn't speak english
when i was little
so english is my second language always
has been
and always will be um a female
you can't deny it's what it is although
i've been treated as one of the guys my
entire life
i was always the only female in the room
until
i was able to make be a part of a group
of people that make the change so that
you no longer are because i
also don't understand that part of it
there's a lot of women
that love to be the only ones and i'd
love to have those women come and chat
with us
please
okay we'll find us they're easy to find
that is not the kind of shining star
that you should
that you should have as a badge of honor
uh
but and i'm gay so that
take another one and um i i have an
adopted child
take another i mean like you name it
bring it on i'm over 50 so i'm a senior
you mess with me girls i'm a senior so
more respect
so i mean like it's one after the other
but within our community
we tend to discriminate our own as well
yeah you know what i mean because
i think i think that may have to do a
little with our post-colonial legacy too
right
of class and race and
all of the baggage that we carry from
the colonization i think the class
conversation is a big one
with regard to why are we not seen in
hollywood because who
is making even you know who's making
content and and what is
how do you who is deciding what's
important
versus what's you know whatever the
opposite of important
is you know their films have to have
been important
and that's very interesting when
the group that you know is making that
decision
is primarily not
of color or not
upper middle class or not you know all
of those things
i think it's very important to consider
all of that
and i think fortunately that's been
happening it's been being considered the
academy letting all these people in in
the last few years has been
a great step toward that but still you
know there's language
i i i always think about that the
important
how are we deciding who's deciding
i wanna i wanna make sure that um i pick
on your phrase
the academy letting people oh my god i
was gonna say the same thing enemy
is inviting people that deserve to be in
they're not
letting them in to see that we're
letting them in is saying that they have
no place
on earth being up here goes with my
feisty you invited me here i am
we belong we have a place
in your table the academy is now taking
a look
who are the guests for that dinner table
and
we are invited to join in fact
they can decline the invite by the way
they don't have to be
uh they have to say yes but i think that
is so
important and part of this not only the
patriarchy but
in just this um and how we attack
this inclusivity and equality
that we change how we talk about our
people
allowing us to come in you don't get to
allow me
and that's the thing it's not charity
it's equality and there are many
qualified people over the years who are
not
invited and uh and so i was just going
to say the same thing it's not like
you know oh thank you so much for
letting me in because i did not feel
that way
it felt like you know we have so many
people
of talented caliber in our community
that just don't recognize the same thing
with the with the um
drama with american dirt when the author
of that oprah book club said
i wish somebody browner than me wrote
the book about immigration and everybody
in the publishing
i mean every author goes it has been
written
oprah didn't pick them yep enrique
so-and-so and and
and raqqa like this book has been
written 18 times by a person of color
that that book was not picked by the
publishing industry your book was picked
and so you know that's what happens when
you don't have
a victoria uh uh uh had that has a seat
at the table when you don't have a
lorenza
who has a seat at the table in these
very uh
uh huge institutions that we feel
sometimes are impenetrable
so it's so important that you guys are
there
[Music]
i completely get that and actually it's
like i'm
it's i appreciate that you pointed that
out because it also speaks to like maybe
how did i feel
when i get got invited right like it's
it's it's a way to explore your own
connection to it but also
you know for me i really words do matter
and
and for me when we talk about inclusion
i always
say i always change it to correcting
exclusion
so i'm very because it's i don't want to
be included i want you to fix
that you let me that you left me i have
that i'm gonna use it can i use it
absolutely yeah i mean but that's real
like that's the thing about language
language is so important with all of
this especially for
us yeah sorry language perspective
all and and you all have you know carmen
certainly has been
fighting the good fight victoria i don't
need to tell you
what a fighter that one is and thank god
she's been in the room with us
and yvette and nadia as well i mean it's
it's been
a very interesting thing to observe at
the academy how we broaden people's
uh perspectives shall we say
in a nice way i wanted to just make a
point also it's um
the people in power right they have this
european pov
pov right and they're surrounded by
people who look like them
talk like them think like them and have
the same background and so
that that's where that's where we really
need to like
see change happen right because we we
can keep talking about this
and i've been in those rooms and as well
carmen yes
and it's sort of shocking um our
perspectives
and our um stories are being whole are
in a chokehold
in the hollywood ecosystem and structure
and so until
we have we are in that room i'm afraid
we're not going to see the change
that we need to see
nadia you wanted to say something and we
kept cutting you off i'm so sorry i
didn't know it's interesting i had an
interesting experience
um even when you mentioned the backlash
about um
your your film um when i made
a documentary called after maria and
for my whole life i wanted to make
something that could explore
puerto rican identity in the us and
just the complexity of what that is to
be
a citizen in the united states you know
not speak the language
you know be called all types of names
and and all these things and something
that i always wanted to do
so when hurricane maria happened um
i decided to make a film you know i knew
i wanted to make a film
around the story of families that were
leaving the island
and coming to new york to um you know
find a new life not die on the island
all the things that were happening and
so
i ended up telling the story i made a
documentary about three moms who
met on the same floor in a fema hotel
and the relationship that they built
between them
um trying to survive the bureaucracy of
fema and the experience that they were
having and um
so the the film uh you know get screened
by netflix and they they they take this
movie and so
as they started to um play the the
trailer of the film there was all this
excitement around
this film you know because we made it
relatively quickly and
you know uh puerto rico was still in the
news and people
were just like i can't wait to see this
movie this is gonna be like the tell all
film
of what happened in puerto rico the
expose
and it wasn't it was a character story
about three moms that became friends and
helped raise each other's kids and
survive this experience but
we had such a tremendous backlash on
this film
from the puerto rican community mainly
for a couple reasons one was
people had these high hopes of seeing
themselves
every version of themselves in this
movie
right so they people felt it should have
been this like epic eight part
netflix series about what happened in
hurricane maria and it was not
um and so anyone that didn't feel like
their story was represented
was angry um and then the film
was made by women who i fell in love
with that reminded me of my own
family members my own mother and there
were issues around
class and some people felt that i
portrayed
low-class puerto ricans in this film and
it was such an interesting experiment
for me to have this experience where i
made something that
is so dignifying and heartfelt and
beautiful and
people had all these different
interpretations of it and then at the
same time i had
so many people that said i can't believe
you told this story this is so
amazing i see myself in this and i've
never seen puerto ricans on screen
with this level of complexity and so um
what it what it showed me was that
there's this a huge void
in hollywood and what we're seeing on
television
where everyone holds on to this idea
that this one
film which was like 38 minutes
was going to tell everyone's story
and the disappointment that existed when
they didn't feel like their story was
told
and how much more we need to tell
stories so that people can see
themselves but since our all of our
identities are so different
that's not going to happen with one film
and
for platforms and streamers and whomever
to understand that there's also this
desperate desire to see this from an
audience
and you know there's so much opportunity
there that's not
being given to filmmakers well i think
you bring up such an important point
because if you're the only movie
they're gonna tear it apart for all the
reasons when you're one of the many
movies
right then you can always reference well
he portrayed this well but it didn't do
it like x movie or that movie but you're
the only movie to do it so you have
nothing but to do it right and it's
impossible to do it right that's why
uh one of the things that eva said when
she started
is like i don't i don't want to do this
when i
when i step on set i want i need to
check this this this it's like no you
have to direct
as long as you get your story right who
cares if you're wearing a jean shirt or
a regular t-shirt or a
low cut or no cut or who nobody you know
what i mean that
that kind of pressure it it puts the
spotlight on
there is true racism within
the latin community you know what i mean
that the higher class doesn't want to be
portrayed as the lower class the lower
class doesn't always want to portray be
portrayed as the people that need things
because a lot of them are trying not to
need it and i mean like there's
it's constant right yeah
and then and then my identity as as a
puerto rican
was totally put into question you know
like i'm an eurekan from the bronx i
don't speak spanish
i'm gonna i'm you know i'm afro-puerto
rican i'm not
light-skinned puerto rican so
i'm like this is insane but it also was
so cathartic at the same time that
it um you know i think once you get over
the initial
sort of processing
it's it i i felt like i was really able
to explore something deep within myself
through my work that i had been wanting
to do like my whole life you know
yeah i think also what stacy's report
did
also was offer um solutions because i
think sometimes
big companies big studios are paralyzed
by this
problem and they think just cast cast
cast
cast and you're like no no we need
change across
casting building a pipeline for latino
filmmakers whether it's writers or
producers or directors
um urging urging studios to hire latino
talent for advertising
um and the trailers and the there's
companies that do that that are latino
owned
so so making sure we're inclusive in in
the entire ecosystem of the industry um
and in the industry sectors would really
help
uh our it would it would go a long way
and i think sometimes we only focus
on casting right cast more cast more and
you're like no no
there's so much more in the
infrastructure of opportunity that has
to be
created for us but it does go to the
some latin kids young adults
don't know these doors exists exist
except for
on camera because that's all they see
they don't see what i do
they don't see what yvette does or what
carmen or nadia does they only see
about what you do right or what you used
to do i know you're directing and then
you
you've always produced but we need to
inform and educate our own that's why
i mean i know event you and i and
lorenzo of course we do
a lot of things together but this is why
i encourage
everyone to do the panels go to the
schools
go to conferences show your faces tell
them
it happened to me i didn't know anybody
i didn't know anybody and i came from
far away and so the kids understand oh i
could do that
oh i don't have to have a 17-year degree
to do it because
i just have a high school diploma it's
okay i'll teach you
it's all good you don't have to i mean
not to say i don't want him to go to
college but
it's important for us to teach the the
young generations to know that
you don't have to have all the things
that they think they have to in order to
be
a part of it if you don't do it in front
of camera and
on that note um i know eva has to
run so you don't but i want to say i
love you ladies i love you so much
me too so great talking to you
and now i will turn it over to sean
finney for our final
questions that was so amazing so
beautiful thank you all so much for
coming and just sharing your light and
your stories
um yvette i i wanted to start with you
just because you mentioned something
about
what i think is so important in the
latino community is that you are so many
things right so a lot of everyone can be
ethnically ambiguous
um do you often and for all of you do
you feel misunderstood
uh because they may not understand
victoria you're from argentina
and and nadia you're a new yorker and
yvette you're this do you often feel
that
completely misunderstood in the
community as well as
people not in the community in the
latino community or in the industry
in the industry um yeah
they're com they're perplexed um
um they're they don't know quite how
like what i
am i think that there's a lot i mean i
spoke about it a little bit earlier but
you know
our educational system right we are
completely erased from our history
and our contributions so nobody
understands the difference and i didn't
even know my own
my own history until i went out and
bought a bunch of books on puerto rico
right and then that's when i learned
like and then i got my dna and i could
see the map i'm like oh west africa
north
africa here i go like i mean it was just
fascinating to me
that's not something i learned in a
history book or in you know advanced
learning and then so we don't have and
i'm really excited about
fingers crossed the american latino
museum on the hill
that's going to be a beautiful place
where people can come and learn about
our
culture and our history and um in
hollywood right hollywood has
hollywood could help us get there
quicker because everything else is going
to take a minute
but hollywood has the power right now
right here
to make a difference and to help us tell
our story so that people aren't afraid
of us and they're not stereotyping us
so really it's it's hollywood that i'm
talking to hollywood like you have
this is not rocket science it's really
not
i think it's important not to dilute
your story to blend in
and i think what we've been trying to do
for so long
is to blend in why because it's better
that way
if you blend in they're not going to
single you out and
and you can't you can not blend in as a
female
uh if that's how you define yourself
then
then you have to diff just blend in in
every other way
right you're going to have enough you're
going to be discriminated as a female so
just
shut up don't sit just you know if you
have an accent
work on it so people don't hear it uh i
refuse to work on my accent it is what
it is
whether you like it or you don't like it
i love it uh
and and don't get me pissed off because
i'll start rattling in spanish and i'll
just say it all and
let's just hire a ghost
it's just how it goes i mean like i i so
many times
people say i love it when you start
singing in spanish i do i just i
you know uh i people used to say to me
are you italian
and it was what that invite you know
that sexy invite to say yes you say
yes so that we can actually con i'm like
well my grandparents were but no i am
full-on argentinian
and that was and victoria do you
remember when it was the italians and
the irish
who were discriminated again so that's
the interesting thing now they're cool
everything has a flow but i think that
the more of us
that are out there talking about it the
more of our stories the more that
the more times that nadia gets
to tell that story that puerto rican or
euro rican a new re
whatever however you want to call it
nadia and
maybe the in your next film you tell the
other story
uh after maria because those were three
mothers there were
thousands thousands that were affected
um
and maybe is the one after the
earthquake who knows but
you told a different story with becoming
and you and
it's always enriching the fact that
behind
that camera there is a person that
represents us
you know what i mean and then we can
talk about it and the minute that people
see
it that it happened to you and it
happened to me
and lorenza and carmen and yvette and
eva
and many others you don't have to be
penelope cruz
or salma hayek there's other women out
there that are doing it and that's the
most important thing you can be
um in any other place in the film
industry and there's so many places that
you can be to make a difference
absolutely i do think to speak to your
victoria to your um
to what you were saying like specificity
for me it's been very exciting in these
last
i think only really five years um
to see these voices telling their own
stories
our own stories and and i think until
there is real specificity to the
narratives it's
it is gonna be like oh here's a cast you
know make the supporting person
latin or make her black and i even for
me who
is all about as i said correcting
exclusion
i don't find that to be any kind of
solution i actually find that to be
somewhat
i don't want to say racist but it's you
know it doesn't solve any problems but
it makes people feel like something has
happened and i don't like participating
in that if there's a story
reason for the supporting character to
be
latin or black then fantastic or if
you're going to change that story
if you're going to enrich that character
in a way that is specific then great
but when you get these these
storytellers telling their own stories
that doesn't have to happen because it's
natural it's natural to the story
it's it's just like it is natural in our
actual lives
are you saying that you rather not have
the supporting roles be
of people of color because it's not
necessarily that story that they're
telling
i prefer if that and this is something
that i
generally try to do and i'm pretty
successful with it
in having a dialogue with the filmmakers
and saying like
you know great yes but is there
something that makes
this relevant i also agree with you know
trying to just make the entire thing
more diverse and it doesn't have to be
specific but i'm saying
for us to move forward like just even
just a little tweak of like give that
person a reason
to have been latin in
you know at the jpl or whatever um
again because i think it does speak to
the specific
i agree with you um carmen and actually
we both
i worked on vida on second season i mean
you did an amazing job with vida but
for me as a marketer talking to our
media and having to
really you know talk to all the
organizations and say
i do not want you to come out and start
talking about the fact that this is a
story about lgbtq and that's isla
like i i literally had to speak to them
in advance to say do not come out and
just
this one story is a very specific story
that was so beautifully told
that it's not everybody's story you know
and so and and
the specificity of what you did with
that specific um show i mean
i loved it i love every character in
that in that series
they're amazing thank you i think it is
it's about
allowing ourselves to be our full selves
and in that one it is it's about being
sisters that story is about being
sisters that's it universal
different they're very universal and one
is gay and the other one is not
and then the mother it's we're sisters
and i think the people
love to pigeonhole us into the one thing
and i understand they have to sell
it and i understand they have to um
in this moment in time they have to sort
of look good and saying
no no we're we are inclusive
we or you know we're trying direct
exclusion as carmen says and that's my
favorite line of it all the whole day
today
i'm so glad that i heard it but i think
it's important that
can we just be women can we just be moms
sisters partners friends and then
the moment that we start taking the
things that makes us so different
we start belonging and we we tell that
to ourselves and we tell that
to society it's like where if you look
at every single netflix show
that is here now from every country i've
seen them all
because i see everything from all over
the world we're not that different we
all have the same problems
absolutely of course i mean we speak
another language
we may look a little different but truly
it's about the pursuit of happiness the
lack of friendship the need to decide
the fear of dying
i mean i can go on and on it's universal
absolutely it's very much universal and
netflix is such a great
um platform i watch all of the same i
love it so much i mean i'm watching
every country and i and i always think
to myself hollywood
studios why why can't you do this why
can't you look at what netflix is doing
it's amazing i mean it's it's right
there for you just to understand that
there is a um an audience a global
audience
i think slowly but surely everyone is
getting the um
they're they're hearing the bell which
has been raining for a long time
yeah but you say something victoria that
i will never forget
and and that's like you're one until
we're 30 percent of the room
until we're 30 of the room we're really
not going to see
a change right we don't change we don't
we don't turn the room
i always say that you can be the one
person or the two percent or the three
percent the problem is
30 has enough weight right to start
changing the conversation
you you still can be toppled by the
other 70
but when you're just one voice in a room
uh where there's 10 people you're just
one single voice and then you're two
then you're just that pair that is
always
then all of a sudden there's three
people talking about it so it's not just
the rattlers
there's somebody else and then somebody
in the room
again of 10 finds themselves to have
permission to hear what you're saying
they
allow themselves to hear it because more
than one person says it
and then then you turn to start
to be heard because you may be being
listened to but
if you're not heard you're not going to
turn the room to where it needs to or if
nothing else
to be heard sometimes we just want you
to consider it
like carmen is saying consider
not excluding us just consider it
consider giving that character a
backstory as opposed to
latin boy 17.
just consider it and that to me is part
of why
not only are we talking about it in all
these rooms but people are
listening and we're being heard which is
the next step
to just you know listening for because
you politically have to do it i think
what's
interesting about the the 30
is that for me that that feels
like it's going to take a long time
because we have to have a pipeline right
and these people have to have experience
and we have to
we have to really build it and
that's hopefully what's happening don't
get caught up on the pipeline we built
the studio without knowing nothing about
how to do it
and that's how marvel studio was born
please don't get caught up on there
we would not just do it just do it
please
do it i mean we are all doing it i think
everyone else has
to come on board that's the thing they
have to do it
and i want to say that one thing that
lycolab is doing is meeting with studios
and they are looking um we there's there
are a lot of latinos that are qualified
guys for
these jobs fyi so i do believe in the
pipeline and all that but really there's
a lot of us
and um and so what i'm what i'm seeing
is that a lot of them are open
to have to having this conversation we
are collecting resumes and sending them
their way
so there are a lot of latinos that are
ready so um
you know i think it's important and i
had a conversation with the head of a
studio
that reached out that for me to possibly
come inside and leave my company
and one of the things he he wanted to
sit with me and ask me why certain films
didn't work
and when he brought up this film and i
told him his face
dropped and he was shocked he was
absolutely shocked that
and why didn't anybody tell me that and
i said because no one looked like me in
the room
you know and this is exactly what if you
don't you're making decisions without us
in the room it's just
you're leaving money on the table it's
really simple it's not physically
responsible is it
no it isn't yeah it's it's silly
well mujeres thank you so much this has
been so incredible i know we could sit
here
and talk for hours and hours and we have
to do that at some point once covet ends
right we'll do it in person
i just want to thank you so much what an
amazing group of women
i'm so proud and i'm so happy that
you're all here
hi i'm carmen cuba thank you for
watching academy dialogues